...
-Tu t'en vas...
Quelques jours...
En attendant ton retour...
Chaque rose...
Chaque chose...
Disaient
à bientôt nous deux.
Tu t'en vas...
Quelques jours...
En attendant ton retour...
Chaque rose...
Chaque chose...
T'on dit
à bientôt nous deux.
Tu vois, tu vois...
Il te parlait pour moi.
Car moi, car moi...
Je t'aimais trop pour ça.
Mon coeur tout bas chantait...
Comme à bientôt nous deux.
[Flûte.]
...
Bien longtemps...
Ton refrains...
M'a suivi sur le chemin.
Sa musique...
nostalgique...
disait...
à bientôt nous deux.
Tu vois, tu vois...
Il te parlait pour moi.
Car moi, car moi...
Je t'aimais trop pour ça.
Ton départ n'est pas un...
adieu.
A bientôt nous deux.
Que la lune...
Que la brume...
Nos vieux amis d'autrefois.
Et la brise...
te redise...
pour mois
à bientôt nous deux.
Que la brise...
Que la brume...
Nos vieux amis d'autrefois.
Et la brise...
te redise...
pour moi...
à bientôt nous deux.
[Applaudissements.]